dieses phänomen auf dem mond ist
wirklich äußerst mysteriös immer wieder
mal flackern rätselhafte
lichterscheinung und kurze lichtblitze
an der mondoberfläche auf und zwar
mehrmals in der woche und das seit
jahrzehnten forschungsteams weltweit
haben keine ahnung was ist damit auf
sich haben könnte
ein forschungsteam aus würzburg hat
jetzt ein neues teleskop an den start
gebracht um dieses phänomen endlich
aufzuklären kicks science fiction hier
gibt es täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
die mysteriöse phänomene auf dem mond
raupen astronomie teams weltweit den
schlaf und das schon seit den 1950 er
jahren als man sie das erste mal
beobachtet hatte doch auch heute noch
gibt es keine eindeutige erklärung der
langfristige und systematische
beobachtungen fehlen dafür unglaublich
viele spekulationen werden diese leuchte
erscheinung etwa ausgelöst durch lunare
meteoriteneinschläge ein kurzzeitiges
aufleuchten könnte durchaus durch den
aufprall eines meteors verursacht werden
oder stecken etwa wechselwirkungen des
sonnenwindes mit dem mond regolith
dahinter schließlich reagieren die
elektrisch geladenen teilchen des
sonnenwindes mit den mondstaub artikeln
der raumfahrttechniker hakan kayal von
der universität würzburg hat noch eine
weitere mögliche erklärung am start auf
dem mond wurden auch seismische
aktivitäten beobachtet bei bewegungen
der oberfläche könnten aus dem
mondinneren gase austreten die das
sonnenlicht reflektieren
das würde die leuchterscheinung erklären
die teils über stunden anhalten
hakan kayal ist einfach ich bei der
suche und höchst motiviert und so hat er
zusammen mit seinem team ein eigenes
mohn teleskop gebaut und im april in
einem privaten aufseher thorium in
spanien in betrieb genommen hier sind
die wetterbedingungen um längen besser
als in deutschland um den mond ins
visier zu nehmen für die experten und
expertinnen ist die große entfernung von
würzburg nach spanien aber kein problem
denn das teleskop wird aus würzburg
ferngesteuert insgesamt zwei kameras
haben dem mond fortlaufend im blick wenn
beide einen leuchtend registrieren
werden fotos und videos gemacht das ist
ja inzwischen so möglich dass auch im
nachhinein
ab dem moment vor dem ereignis eine
aufnahme abgespeichert werden kann
diese werden dann nach würzburg
geschickt um von den fachleuten
ausgewertet zu werden wenn diese dann
feststellen dass tatsächlich eine
leuchte erscheinung dokumentiert werden
konnte werden die entsprechenden daten
mit daten der europäischen
raumfahrtagentur esa verglichen wenn
auch dort entsprechende phänomene
registriert werden konnten soll
dahingehend weitere intensive forschung
betrieben werden derzeit ist das
teleskop auswärtspunkt durch alles was
so zwischen dem mond und dem teleskop
passiert noch etwas fehleranfällig aber
genau daran wird gearbeitet der plan
sieht vor künstliche intelligenz zu
nutzen so könnte das system selbst
lernen unterscheidungen zu treffen und
zwar zwischen wichtigen ereignissen wir
heben den mond blitzen und unwichtigen
ereignissen wie beispielsweise dem
vorbeiflug eines vogels an der kamera
schon im kommenden jahr sollen neuronale
netzwerke diese arbeit übernehmen
langfristig gesehen hat das team um
karin aber noch größere ziele
das system soll schon bald auf einer
satelliten missionen eingesetzt werden
die kameras könnten dann ohne die
störung die sich durch die atmosphäre
ergeben im störungsfreien weltraum
arbeiten vor allem im hinblick auf
zukünftige bemannte mondmissionen ist
die klärung dieses lunaren rätsels
wirklich erstrebenswert dazu hk wer
irgendwann eine mondbasis traum will
muss die gegebenheiten vor ort natürlich
bestens kennen und nicht nur das
us-amerikanische aufwand oder nehmen
space ex von ihnen masse sondern
beispielsweise auch china sehen den mund
als einen möglichen neuen lebensraum für
uns menschen somit ist auch die rückkehr
von astronauten an astronauten zum mond
fest geplant bereits im jahr 2024 soll
ja eine bemannte us raumsonde auf dem
mond landen aber ob das alles so hinhaut
da gibt es ja zweifel haben auch die esa
möchte eine mondbasis errichten und auch
indien zeigt großes interesse
wenn auch zunächst nur mit unbemannten
sonden der wettlauf zum mond hat also
längst begonnen warum die mondlandung
kein fake war anklicken anschauen und
zum team von oslo comics tv einen dicken
gefallen abonniert seinen kanal heute er
braucht nur noch ein paar abos bis
10.000 also ich denke er wird sich
tierisch über die überraschung freuen
bis dann bleibt werden